this is Meg from finding a movie clips
with things to know before you see
sinister - like beware the boogeyman or
as he's known in the sinister world
Bakul he's a persistent dude and once
you see him you're pretty much sinister
ends with crime novelist Ellison Oswalt
played by Ethan Hawke dead on the floor
of his own home but that's what you get
for breaking the number one rule for
surviving a horror film never move your
family into a murder families home to be
fair he couldn't have known that super
evil pagan deity but ghoul was creeping
around the corner the ghoul Lord poor
Oswalt to watch kill films which are
basically deranged selfies the kids
murdering their own families his these
days am i right
don't worry parents these kids were
manipulated by Fogle and part of his
children of the corn army sinister -
picks up with detective so-and-so played
again by James Ranson continuing the
investigative work he started with
Oswald in the first film this leads him
to an isolated farmhouse where mom
Courtney portrayed by Shannyn Sossamon
and her twin sons run into trouble with
none other than but ghoul let me get
down for you Courtney you've got an
isolated farmhouse and you've got twins
you're just asking for it think of
Google as a combo of Pennywise the clown
from it and slender man from creepypasta
wiki whoops stared thinking about it
well this time around babul invites the
twin boys to movie night making them
watch the kill film's director Ciaran
Foy promises crazier kill films than one
including a hanging electrocution and
death by rats
beware viewers with Musa phobia voice
strive for authenticity in the kill
films shooting them on 16 millimeter
Kodak 7219 film stock using an re flex
416 camera with zeiss supersede primes
and Canon zooms on a 4:3 aspect ratio
translation they look just like your
Grandpa's old home videos sinister to
Marx Kieran boys first big-budget film
after earning critical acclaim for his
heart indie Citadel remember - comes
from a long lineage of celebrated modern
horror scott derrickson director of
sinister deliver us from evil and The
Exorcism of Emily Rose co-wrote - with
see Robert Cargill and co-produced along
with Jason Blum of Blum house
productions I'm Meg from pending a movie
clips thanks for watching don't forget
to subscribe visit fandango.com for
sinister 2 tickets and remember scary
movies aren't real
you